i set you up with the question you can
have the first bit are you sure you sure
i don't you don't have to do that okay
i'll let you have it well you know where
i'm going here i mean come on
you know where am i going
i don't know you go there i don't want
to give you my first i'm going with the
new england patriots okay i mean i don't
care you know there's one guy that's
doing a double part of the trio but i'm
going there first off the best head
coach in the history of football is bill
belichick not even close i mean vince
lombardi may be the closest one that's
second right okay there's no defense
coordinator there right now but it's
bill belichick they have nobody on the
staff either way okay that's a pretty
damn good combination bill belichick and
bill belichick okay then the third one i
think this is the best offensive play
caller in the sport right now josh
mcdaniels his offense his ability to
change game plans do different things on
a weekly basis reinvent themselves find
different ways to win i don't think
anybody's better than josh at designing
game plans on the offensive side of the
ball right now and there's a lot of ones
out there you know i respect mcveigh my
buddy kyle shanahan sean payton but i
think mcdaniel's at the top so i got to
go with the patriots to start this
yeah all right well that's my birthday
present to you i didn't get you anything
uh but there's your gift because yeah
that's the obvious first pick even
though the patriots don't have a
defensive coordinator gerard mayo is
going to call the plays apparently
defensively but it is belichick it is
mcdaniels and that's all you need and
frankly i i'll do respect to mcdaniels
all you need is belichick i think they'd
be fine even if mcdaniels wasn't there
as the offensive coordinator all right
now it gets very difficult there are a
lot of different ways we can go but you
know what there aren't many coaches that
can say they have out-patrioted the
patriots and doug peterson found a way
to do it now i feel more strongly about
this if frank wright was still the
offensive coordinator but mike grow
again peterson's an offensive guy so
peterson kind of has that influence that
that bleeds into the offense and then
you got jim schwartz the defensive
coordinator who for whatever reason has
not gotten a second opportunity to be an
nfl head coach even though he has done
great things with that eagles defense
they are a shortlist super bowl
contender this year as long as carson
wentz can stay healthy and they showed
us what they could do even without wentz
in the super bowl for all the marbles
against bill belichick against josh
mcdaniels and matt patricia was there
right i i this this probably
i'm with you i mean that's all i can
really say you know doug peterson mike
grow they're both kind of like de facto
offensive coordinators grow probably
does a lot of the heavy lifting and then
you know peterson steps in and tweaks
and fixes things or whatever it may be
and jim schwartz is a hell of a
defensive football coach there's no
doubt hit a little hit a little hard
time there from the super bowl and maybe
early on last year but like a great
coach he adjusted and found different
ways to make that defense a real pain in
the butt especially as injured as they
were on that side of the ball through
the middle of last season so i'm with
you it's again i think it's the only
organization that i look at from top to
bottom right now that i go oh they're
real close to the new england way they
have a different style they don't do it
like new england but certainly
impressive in all facets of their
organization so i'm with you there okay
now this is where it gets interesting i
think those were the obvious two first
picks for me
i i still and i know and even though i'm
expecting a little bit of a letdown here
okay i'm i'm going with the los angeles
rams i i just i have to okay with sean
mcvay i mean come on it speaks for
itself head coach offensive genius mike
i don't even know who their de facto
offensive coordinator is right now i
didn't even look it up i'll do it as we
sit here and talk about this but either
way
wade phillips on the other side of the
ball uh is one of the great defensive
minds in the history of the sport let
alone he was a pretty successful head
coach to go along with it i just look at
that combination there and then know
that yeah mcveigh at the very least and
i know you're not looking this up so i
have to look it up now because you know
i did my homework um
no run game quarter there is no oc there
is none they have run game and past game
coordinators they're not so mcveigh is
the guy and that's why i go with rams
yeah i think that makes sense even
though there is a sense that maybe the
rest of the nfl is beginning to catch up
with sean mcvay's offense only three
points scored in super bowl 53 against
the patriots and you wonder whether to
what extent other teams can replicate
what the patriots did based upon the
film study based upon you know do you
have the guys to pull it off and also
the todd gurley health factor how is
that going to affect the rams this year
offensively all right now
yeah it gets no it gets no easier right
and i you know i'm gonna go with the new
orleans saints and sean payton pete
carmichael who never gets even mentioned
as a possible head coaching candidate
because everybody gives credit for the
offense to sean payton carmichael's been
there for so long i think he has to get
some of that credit and then dennis
allen who had look
he was the raiders head coach and he
probably never should have taken that
job sean payton at one point rejected
the opportunity to take the raiders head
coaching job but alan has done well in
his second act in new orleans that
defense after i thought that the bounty
gate that last year in 2012 decimated
the franchise and it took them years to
get back to a point where they felt like
they could contend again and even though
they had a great offense you know i mean
they had a horrible defense and they
were still around 500 they weren't a bad
team but now they've been an elite team
all over again and i think that
combination led by sean payton yeah who
can draw up the the plays for any given
game he's got a you know he always is
thinking of different ideas different
innovations always trying to stay ahead
of the competition offensively and it
shows week in and week out it's one of
the reasons why drew brees is one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time his
work with sean payton has helped him
tremendously so i'll take the saints for
my second pick yeah i get you there all
the way and it's really you know again
like i know both of us question can the
saints rebound and do things you know
this year after two heartbreaking
seasons and how it all you know ended uh
the reason i still think they're gonna
be very relevant is because of sean
payton i just think his toughness his
creativity it shows on the field it
shows on film when i watch it and you
know again even through this preseason
there's been a lot of things to be
impressed about with that saints
football team and yeah pete carmichael
their offensive coordinator who we know
sean payton's very involved there is uh
he's no slouch himself so that's a
pretty damn good three it's hard to
argue that oh okay
now i get down to i mean i'm just gonna
talk this out i don't care if you steal
one of my picks okay because uh i look
at the ravens the bears the chargers
those are three teams that are on my
list i look at the chargers and go man
you know there's gus bradley ken
wizzenhunt and anthony lynn who i
respect but i think ultimately i'm gonna
go with the baltimore ravens right now i
am you know uh i know first off john
harbaugh for me is one of the best nfl
head coaches there is out there i mean
come on the ravens are relevant every
year just about uh they play with such
great physicality and toughness they
have an edge about them they do things
the right way
he manages special teams and situations
the correct way i just think he's a
great head coach then don wink
martindale on the defensive side the
ravens were one of the best defenses in
football last year but they won or were
they two they were one and i know he's
new to the defensive side but man it's
it's a lot the don dean p's system they
do a lot of creative things on a
week-to-week basis i really think the
world of uh wink martindale and then
greg roman
i mean again he doesn't blow my doors
off like maybe a mcvay or sean payton or
shanahan but the damn guy did go and
kind of invent a new style of offense
for colin kaepernick with the san
francisco 49ers and do some pretty damn
good things to where they went to the
super bowl and i'm excited to see what
he has this year he's at least a proven
commodity there to where i go that's a
pretty strong three
i thought
seriously about the ravens but because
we don't yet know what that offense is
going to be with greg roman as the
coordinator it's too early to say and
now i have faith that it's it's going to
work but i want to see and it's yeah and
because they've been so careful and
deliberate about what they have shared
with the world i i can't evaluate at
this point what the ravens offense is
going to be so that's why i didn't go
with them i like your charger suggestion
i'm not going to take that one from you
i've i mean i've got the colts on my my
list sorry as potential i've got the
bears with reigning coach of the year
matt nagy right um i and and uh i yeah
i'm going to go ahead and go with the
chiefs you are with andy reid okay eric
b enemy who
who did a gr a spectacular job last year
as offensive coordinator and got no
sniffs to be a head coach and you bring
in steve spagnolo who look all due
respect to bob sutton the coordinator
last year but that defense stunk and
they still almost made it to the super
bowl yeah and spagnolo comes in with a
4-3 and they've retooled the personnel
and i think those guys all together and
spagnola together again with andy reid
and we saw what spagnolo did as the
giants defensive coordinator the year
that they beat the patriots and held the
14 points in the super bowl i i uh i'm
ready to buy in and say that yes i mean
it and i know andy reid has trouble
managing the clock late in the game look
the way this team plays you don't you
don't need to worry about this team has
the potential to blow the doors off of
people and if the defense is just a
little bit better this year we're going
to see a lot of 42 to 17 final scores
yeah i i do think we'll see a lot of
that i do expect the defense at the very
least like you said to be improved i
mean they can't really go down uh right
but uh i i really love reading the enemy
and i like the addition of spags i guess
i just have some questions about
spagnola a little bit just because yes
that was an incredible super bowl
performance in 2007 and some of the
things he did with the new york giants
football team but i also look at some
other you know issues when he was with
the saints and you know other other
spots where i just go gosh it was kind
of all over the map that's what stopped
me from picking the chiefs a little like
you said with me with greg roman i want
to see a little bit more of the new
version of steve spagnuolo defense
before i picked them
yeah i i that was a fun draft i wish we
would have gone four or five rounds i
hated leaving people out but as it
stands three rounds patriots rams ravens
for sims i've got eagles saints chief
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports